all right so the MTV Movie Awards have
aired and I didn't watch it I haven't
watched it I have no need to watch it
because the MTV Movie Awards are pretty
much the end result of a circle jerk of
a bunch of tasteless tweens I don't care
to see it however it did produce one
thing worth talking about Nats the new
Dark Knight Rises TV spot and I'm sorry
I can't show footage of this trailer in
this video every YouTube channel on
every website that dares show the MTV
trailer for The Dark Knight Rises
they've been slapped with one of those
copyright infringement cases no no thank
you
no thank you but I will tell you what I
think about it I don't want to turn my
youtube channel into the unofficial Dark
Knight Rises fanboy channel or anything
like that that's why I haven't talked
about the TV spots I mean every ad and
TV spot I walk away from going yeah it
looks awesome it looks badass
I want to see it a lot I mean how many
times can I convey that into a video
before it becomes repetitive
however this MTV trailer has done
something that the other ones haven't
and that is put me completely on the
side of Anne Hathaway as Catwoman she is
the show stealer in this MTV trailer and
I'm happy to say because before it was
like alright yeah now she's looking
better as Catwoman but I didn't I wasn't
completely sure I'm still not 100%
completely sure it's still a theory at
this point but I'm i theorize that Anne
Hathaway as Catwoman is gonna kick ass I
mean she has certain things that she
says in this trailer that I'm like that
is Catwoman Joseph gordon-levitt he's a
cop and he's grilling her and he's like
why are you trying to run miss Kyle you
can't run from us and she looks like she
just doesn't care that this cop is
grilling her she's like yeah well maybe
it's not you I'm running from I was like
ok Catwoman for the first time since
Batman Arkham City I was excited to see
Catwoman yeah Bane still looks like a
scary and menacing bastard you're gonna
see that in every trailer every trailer
you're gonna walk away from going Bane's
about us and he has a new line too and
he's all like whenever I talk about Bane
I just have to do that voice and the
scene where she's all sitting sexy and
confident on the subway bench she's like
don't be shy it's like is she talking to
Bane and I've always theorized this that
she's gonna work with Bane to a point
and then be like this guy is out of his
mind and she's gonna be like I'm walking
away from the whole bane situation I'm
out which you don't do because he's
going to break your face with his face
moment you're like oh I don't like
paying anymore unsubscribe Bane's gonna
be like I subscribe for me a break Wow
and then it's just bad news for you
Catwoman and I liked how we showed more
of Catwoman and batman working
I hope these aren't spoilers I hope it's
not like oh they don't work together
until the very end because I feel like
now when I watched the movie I'm gonna
be like eventually those two are gonna
work together the scene it shows is kind
of a throwback to Batman Begins she
walks around a corner gets face to face
with one of Bane's goons she's like he's
right behind him he's like who turns
around
Batman's all hanging upside down and it
was cool to see I like this TV spot you
know the final trailer was a really
somber and dark trailer I loved the tone
of it this trailer shows it's like I AG
and have other tones too such as really
exciting which is what this trailer is
so no matter what kind of movie goer you
are I think the Dark Knight Rises has a
trailer out there for you so Bane has
always looked like he's gonna be a
complete badass The Dark Knight Rises
has looked like it's gonna be a complete
kick-ass movie I've always felt this but
now my hat is off to Anne Hathaway as
Catwoman and her sexiness all the
elements now fit in my book and I just I
really want to see this movie and I
found a site that has not had this
trailer pulled from it is the links
below check it out before it does get
pulled yeah we can't have a trailer
that's getting people this psyched and
hyped on YouTube or other websites you
know you gotta pull it from the internet
it makes complete sense in a marketing
standpoint it doesn't so have you seen
this new trailer what did you think and
more importantly what do you think of
Anne Hathaway as Catwoman at this point
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always you feel like what
you've seen here and you wanna see more
clip for us
you